bueno se explica Con qué está este
partido hermano de Italia es el único
que ha permanecido fuera de los últimos
gobiernos italianos también ha sido
capaz de crear una gran colisiona con
Mateo salvini y Silvio berlusconi Y por
último también con cierto malestar que
está creciendo en este país en
particular a raíz de la crisis
energética y si hay inquietud en
particular de los colectivos lgtbi y de
los feministas inquietudes que remiten a
ciertas posibles restricciones de
algunos derechos pienso en el aborto que
está teniendo las mujeres están teniendo
mayores obstáculos en las regiones
administradas ya en este país por
hermanos de Italia y precisamente de
cara al exterior a las relaciones con
Bruselas que podría implicar una
victoria de esta coalición
Pues hay mucha preocupación en la Unión
Europea se trataría en el caso de
victoria de esta coalición de la
coalición más derechista que llega al
poder en un país del bloque europeo
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial hay
preocupación porque Italia también está
recibiendo fondos de recuperación a post
pandémico hablamos de 200 mil millones
de euros y tal vez el principal receptor
Y estos fondos están siendo otorgados a
cambio de una reformas que se tienen que
cumplir y también hay preocupación por
ciertas simpatías que los dos
principales socios de melón y Mateo
salvini y Silvio merconi tienen hacia el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin que
continúa con una guerra mortífera en
Ucrania
Irene en Italia diferencia de la mayoría
de países del continente americano donde
nos encontramos hay un sistema
parlamentario Cómo podemos explicar a
nuestra audiencia Cómo debemos analizar
los resultados que conoceremos hoy esta
noche de Italia bueno el sistema
electoral italiano es sumamente complejo
en verdad habrá que estar atentos a los
porcentajes de Voto que consigue la
coalición ganadora sobre todo en el
senado que donde hay riesgo de mayor
bloqueo y sin el senado italiano se
puede gobernar y también habrá que estar
atentos a los porcentajes y la distancia
que los partidos de la colisión ganadora
tendrán entre sí para entender los
futuros equilibrios entre estos partidos
en un futuro gobierno italiano Y por
último también habrá que ver si la
coalición ganadora consigue esos dos
tercios del parlamento que necesita para
aprobar leyes con mayor rapidez y
también posiblemente cambiar la
Constitución italiana